[Music]
all right welcome everyone this is
predicting the future of web development
I'm Richard Feldman let's start with a
question never gotten to choose your
stack at work like your greenfield
project solely up to you or maybe the
team that you're working on you get to
pick what front-end stack you're working
with okay yeah me too
so I've also been that position the
first time I was in that position was
all the way back in 2006 this is the
first web app that I'd ever worked on
and there were four of us was a start-up
and at the time the thing that was big
in web apps this is where the dawn of
web apps was the lamp stack anyone ever
remember the lamp stack okay yeah Linux
Apache my sequel and then the pea was
overloaded to be PHP Perl and Python and
the reason that Pete was so important
was because basically we did all of the
rendering on the server we would
generate HTML on the fly and then send
it to the browser on every page load and
so this is our first time building a web
app were like okay what do we do well
one way you can choose your text stack
is there's there's an old saying goes
choose boring technology essentially try
to pick something that is mature and
established and used by a lot of people
so here's one example of a 2006 boring
technology this is what we ended up
going with it was the the number one
biggest library ecosystem at the time it
was the most mature option the lamp
stack by considerable margin I was used
by successful companies including the
social networking giant of the day
LiveJournal and so we chose this
technology using this methodology and
this is how we ended up building our
entire startup on Pearl
so since 2006 pearls popularity has not
been the best this is the Google Trends
for like pearl searches since 2006 and
kind of a lesson here is that no just
choosing boring technology is not a
guarantee of safety this doesn't mean
that everything's gonna be okay as long
as you just do what everyone else is
doing right now you kind of have to look
towards the future and try to figure out
like well how are things going to go in
the future now the lesson here is that
it's not necessarily a problem that
pearl declined in popularity the problem
is that if we were trying to hire right
now there's not a lot of people who want
to do pearl development these days
there's not a lot of ecosystem support
compared to what they used to be back
then so it's not necessarily a problem
if something is small but there it is a
problem if people are losing interest in
the technology and just don't really
want to use it anymore so any technology
that we choose no matter how popular how
mainstream how much traction it's got
today is still making a bet on the
future there's no safe option here it's
just a matter of what do we think is
going to happen
the real question I think is any
technology choice we're making today are
we still gonna be happy with that in
5-10 years so predicting is safer than
following blindly like following the
herd and just trying to do what
everybody else is doing is not as safe
of that I think as trying to predict
like what actually is going to happen in
the future and then follow that instead
so I'm gonna be making some predictions
today some concrete predictions I'm
gonna make some predictions about what I
think is going to be true about web
development at the end of 2020 and then
also at the end of 2025 so I'm gonna
break this down into four areas one is
typescript two is web assembly packages
and finally compiled to j/s landscape so
let's start with typescript more like
hype scripts am i right I mean come on
we saw Matthews talk yesterday about
this this graph of like type scripts you
know Google Trends like the opposite of
pearls it's like really taking off a lot
of people are talking about it not even
bother explaining what it is because
you've probably all heard of it he also
drew that the comparison of typescript
and CoffeeScript like a lot of people
have said like well as typescript just
gonna turn out like CoffeeScript what
what is in the future for typescript you
know there's everybody's talking about
it now but are they still gonna be
talking about it and using it in a few
years or is it gonna end up tapering off
the way the CoffeeScript did well two
things to note about this one is that
obviously typescript has already grown
way beyond what CoffeeScript did in
terms of interests if Google searches
are any indication and secondly that
it's trend is still going upwards so we
haven't really seen any indication the
typescript is slowing down so what do we
think it's actually gonna do well
obviously frameworks are all on board I
mean this was certainly not true of
CoffeeScript um like no matter what you
can't relate throw a stone without
hitting some framework that's either got
first class typescript support or is
working on adding it already but despite
this the fact that there are so many
people in the ecosystem getting on board
not a hundred percent of people are on
board there are some things that people
don't like about typescript
for example I saw one tweet that was
complaining about having to deal with
this type I'm not gonna read this whole
thing out because I have a limited
amount of time to give this talk but
obviously like encountering this on a
daily basis is not super pleasant this
is
kind of a really verbose like kind of
difficult to understand thing there's
probably some Java programmers who are
now looking on me like you all made fun
of us with our abstract singleton
Factory proxy beam who's laughing now
David Nolan yesterday said that you know
maybe typescript is kind of like
enterprise JavaScript and I think
there's some truth to that another thing
that people say they don't necessarily
like about typescript is that although
it gives you like more type-checking and
some degree of type safety by design the
type system is unsound and it can let
things slip through to give you a false
sense of security one notable example of
this being any which is essentially
means oh this type it might be anything
who knows we're just gonna find out
which appears four times in this type
signature alone so definitely some
things to like about typescript but I
think the most important factor to try
and predict what what is the future of
typescript
is looking at how it's impacting teams I
hear a lot of teams saying we are trying
typescript or we have used typescript we
are using typescript I hear almost no
teams saying we try typescript and then
we went back to JavaScript actually I
haven't heard of any I just don't wanna
get well actually like after this talk
so I'm gonna say yeah it could
theoretically happen but personally I
actually have not heard of a single team
I'm sure somebody has that went
typescript and then went back so it's
basically a ratchet like people switched
to it and then they don't switch back
and that means that it's going to
continue have to have more and more
growth as long as that's true that's a
really powerful force multiplier so
essentially I mean there's a lot of
truth I think to this tweet like you
know maybe if an individual on a team is
like I don't like typescript but if the
whole team ends up adopting typescript
anyway because that's what the team lead
says we're going with that's the
technical decision is or maybe the
department says we're going with that
and so every team has to get on board
whether or not individuals like it is
that doesn't necessarily mean that
that's gonna change the fact that the
whole team adopted it so based on this I
think typescript popularity is like just
getting started I actually think that
well I'm gonna go on record and say I
predict the typescript ends up basically
taking over the Jerome I'll be specific
about what I mean about that so I think
by the end of 2020 I think that for
commercial projects is going to be the
most common choice that the teams make
for a new project
like if they're in that situation making
a Greenfield choice they're gonna go
typescript rather than JavaScript and I
think by the end of 2025 there will be
more people on a daily basis writing
script in JavaScript without typescript
we'll see if I'm right but I think
that's where things are headed
part 2 web assembly Lynne Clark is one
of the great explainers of our time and
she's done a great job explaining web
assembly so I'm not gonna go into super
much depth on that instead I'm going to
oversimplify what web assembly is as
it's a way to run almost machine code in
the browser and the upshot of this is
that essentially it lets you build
applications that can run much faster
than JavaScript now one possible use for
web assembly is you can use it to
improve the perfecting JavaScript apps
and libraries and stuff so one example
that Lynne gave was you could use this
to make the react reconciler faster just
speed up that one part of the library I
think that's interesting but at the end
of the day I don't personally think
that's like how web assemblies gonna get
used the most or the biggest impact that
it's gonna have and the main reason I
think that is I think that the existing
status quo of JavaScript performance is
pretty widely accepted as like fine the
reason I believe this is in part that
I'm on the Elm core team and a few years
ago we had like a really exciting
release or so we thought that was like
hey look look look how much faster we
made Elm like now like renders faster
than like react and angular and view and
ember like all these things look at look
how great these numbers are and people
are like okay but like you know like
it's fat all the other things are fast
enough so whatever I mean good job but
you know look I think people are pretty
okay with the status quo and so if the
pitch of web assembly is it's like use
the same technologies but they'll be a
bit faster I don't think that's gonna be
enough I think it's much more
interesting for companies like Sigma and
they wrote a blog post actually about
how big a deal if web assembly was for
them so if it was a company that makes
graphics editing software like their
competitors or things like Photoshop and
sketch and they're making a really
really serious like heavyweight app and
this application is all built in C++
like they did not build this Photoshop
competitor using HTML CSS JavaScript
able to with C++ that's what their team
looks like if you're going to work at
figma on this product you're writing C++
all day so essentially what they've
built is is a native application that
happens to be distributed in the browser
they're not really using web
technologies if they attended this
conference
most of what we talked about would not
necessarily be a much used to anyone
building this thing in the actual
application so essentially I think that
the main thing that web assembly is
going to do in the future is this going
to allow browsers to compete with app
stores and installers
like the reason that figma chooses to
build their thing in the browser i
assume is the fact that in order for
people to use it they can just go to a
URL and immediately they're using it
they don't have to install it they don't
have to accept permissions they don't
have to go to an app store
none of that stuff it's a very low
commitment a very easy way to get in
also it is a great sharing story if
you're like in the middle of editing
something and you want to send someone
else a link to be like exactly on the
same page as you are and like they can
just bring it up in their browser that's
also really easy in browsers so there's
a lot of good reasons that people might
want to distribute what is fundamentally
a native app in the browser instead of
using an app store or an installer now
another thing that's true about native
apps is they tend to be pretty big in
size like multi megabyte downloads are
kind of a normal thing for native apps
like yeah photo shops like pretty big of
course you know that's what people
expect not so much for with apps we hear
about like the bloat crisis and we're
talking about like kilobytes and if your
if your payload is multiple megabytes
it's like what are you even doing but
again this is the thing where I think
that people you know tolerate this like
the status quo another experience we had
on the ell team was like releasing this
thing where Elms packaged like a bundled
up size it got really small thanks to
like some really aggressive dead code
elimination and this is like not just
the the baseline size that's like across
the entire app so we had this real-world
app which is basically a bigger version
of to do MVC's they have implementations
and react and angular and view and all
these things and the elm one after this
new release went down all the way down
to 29 kilobytes for the entire 4,000
line of code single page app and react
itself is like 35 kilobytes were like
this is amazing look how tiny this is
everyone's talking about this bloat
crisis right it's a really big deal and
people are like good job you know that's
that's you know well done but but the
other day people put up with the multi
megabyte downloads I mean I know like
there's a lot of talk about this stuff
but there's way more talk than action
and we all kind of know that this is
true so I don't see any reason why this
should be different for native apps like
if people are willing to wait for multi
megabyte Photoshop download I think
they'll be willing to wait for that in
the browser to okay so a reasonable
question at this point is it's like okay
so if this is a whole new way of doing
things is this gonna replace the way
that things are done now is everybody
gonna be writing C++ or rust in the
future instead of HTML CSS and
JavaScript is this the end of HTML and
CSS and JavaScript I don't think so no I
think that basically this works for
so many companies making so much money I
don't see why people would change just
because there is another option I mean
they're actually as we'll talk about
later there already are plenty of other
options to HTML CSS and JavaScript and
they're still the most popular by far
I don't think web assemblies gonna
change that I really think the main
impact of web assembly is gonna be that
the definition of what is a web app gets
bigger because it starts to encompass
this additional thing that just was not
popular back in 2006 when we were in the
lamp stack this idea of a native
application distributed through the
browser one particularly compelling
example this I think is games like
imagine rendering this scene where
people can walk around in CSS this is
not happening I mean yeah you need these
like really low-level high performance
technologies if you want to ship a game
in the browser that's only a thing
that's become recently viable like a
plausible thing that you can do but it
actually is a plausible thing that you
can do now and I think there's gonna be
companies they're gonna be taking
advantage of that and start distributing
their games through the browser first so
prediction number two I think
webassembly is going to expand the web
app pie by the end of 2020 honestly I
don't think it's gonna make much of a
noticeable difference I think the people
who are working on these projects are
gonna be starting to work on them around
now but I think by the end of 2025 we'll
start to see okay there actually is a
new neish of like heavyweight web apps
that are basically native apps
distributed in the browser okay why
three packages how many people recognize
this logo shout it out what is it Bower
yes so this was a competing package
manager to NPM they both coexisted for a
while and these days NPM won pretty
convincingly and now Bower usages is
sort of dwindled off like even more so
than Perl so a reasonable question to
ask is like okay that that happened to
Bower could that also happen NPM is
there going to be something that
replaces NPM in the future anyone
recognized this logo no but interesting
this is entropic so there was a talk
given earlier this year this was at JS
conf at the economics of open source by
CJ Silverio and I don't want to steal
her thunder you should watch the talk
and listen to the points that she's
making but essentially she introduces
entropic which is an alternative package
manager it's a bunch of people who
worked at NPM and went on for various
reasons that she explains on the talk to
build a competing package manager
also we've seen competing CLI is like
yarn is another way to you access the
NPM ecosystem and now we're also
starting to see competing backends like
github package registry instead of like
the NPM server ecosystem now worth
noting that I mean yarn is a CLI which
access is the same server hardware and
github package registry is sort of the
opposite I mean it actually on their
website they talk about you use the
normal NPM CLI to access this ecosystem
just point it to a different URL rather
than NPM servers and so reasonable
questions are like okay are these signs
of NPM you know going away and I think
at the end of the day the fundamental
idea of NPM is the real thing that
people are making bets on whether or not
it's yarn or something else I mean
really people are into the network
effects of NPM by which I mean the
package.json file that says here are all
my dependencies and they all have their
dependencies specified in that way
whether it's NPM servers a github
servers or something else I think the
important thing the valuable thing the
thing that people can reasonably
continue to bet on is that that
ecosystem exists and all the network
effects continue to persist I think that
persists through continued problems so
we saw recently not recently this point
a couple years ago I'm left pad where
someone unpublished a package and broke
a lot of people's workflows they closed
that off and said you can't unpublished
packages anymore that's all done earlier
today Chris talked about event stream
like a malicious packet or someone
successfully managed to get up a whole a
hold of a package that was used by a lot
of people and publish a malicious
release so uh hello Alain wrote a really
detailed write-up of the event stream
incident it's on his blog and one of the
things that he talks about is basically
like there was no like one root cause
where you can just close this off and
it's fixed like there was with left pad
this is kind of a more systemic issue
and it's like not really going away
anytime soon this vulnerability is still
there and is gonna be there for the
foreseeable future and something that
neither of those touched on is this so
if I were to install front-end
dependencies by running a bash script
like this what's the difference between
that NPM install which is the way that
most people install front-end
dependencies well one difference is that
when I run bash install that Sh it
execute arbitrary code on your machine
which is a security concern whereas when
you run NPM install in an execute
arbitrary code on your machine from
thousands and thousands of packages
infinitely worse than running a bash
script to like do install that essays
because it's all of your dependencies
and all their dependencies dependencies
you might be thinking what do you mean
I'm executing arbitrary code well
there's this thing called a post install
hook that any package can put in a
package JSON and it will just execute
arbitrary nodejs code which is to say
arbitrary code on your machine
every time that package gets installed
so if that's a virus then cool you just
got a virus and I think the main reason
that this hasn't happened yet is just
that it hasn't happened yet like we
haven't had like the outbreak of the the
NPM virus that someone spreads by using
this this has been disclosed since 2016
NPM wrote a whole blog post about like
hey this is the thing that can happen to
you
and they posted at the end of this blog
post like if you want to disable this
behavior and make it so that post
install scripts and pre install scripts
don't run run this command NPM config
set ignore scripts true and then by
default they just won't run anymore if
you ask me this probably ought to be the
default I've had this enabled for
several years now and although it's less
convenient there are various organ AMA
cashews with it I don't think it's
better than being vulnerable to this
virus if you take nothing else away from
this talk please go home and run this
command so that if there ever is a virus
outbreak you are not affected by it
because I think this is going to happen
III don't see why it wouldn't happen now
that there's like blood in the water and
people have said oh you actually can
publish malicious packages like event
stream interesting ok so in conclusion
though do I think that NPM is going to
go the way of Bower I don't think so I
think NPM is here to stay I think it's
it might have financial troubles github
will probably bail it out by saying
here's that here's alternate servers if
it has more viruses and things like that
I think that it will survive because of
those really strong network effects but
I mean I still wish the entropic folks
all the best of luck but if I'm making a
prediction I think that NPM ends up
surviving whatever further problems come
its way released the ecosystem does so I
think by the end of 2020 I think there
will be at least one more security
incident I think that that seems like a
fairly safe prediction and by the end of
2025 I think there actually will have
been a virus outbreak where someone's
successfully distributed a virus through
an NPM package and it will affect a lot
of people's machines but not those of us
who have run this again please run this
and don't don't be a victim of this ok
which brings me to the final section
compiled to j/s so back in the day if
you didn't want to write javascript in
the browser like 2006 error you could
write Java applets which was awful
or you could write flash which was a
thing until it stopped being a thing
these days the most popular ways to
compile to j/s is to actually compile a
J's dialect to j s so we talked about
CoffeeScript is also dart Babel is like
compiled future js2 current j/s
typescript compile very slight superset
of j s2 j s and smelts which is like
trying to compile to more compact j s
than some of the alternatives all these
fundamentally are basically the same
upsides and same downsides as javascript
i mean they are javascript dialects any
number of them could have the tag line
it's just JavaScript and people be like
ok that's pretty much true even
CoffeeScript had that tag line
typescript certainly does but there are
other options which are not JavaScript
dialects which actually have pretty
different upsides and downsides
javascript we've heard about a couple of
them David Nolan talked about closure
script yesterday we heard about reason
ml from Brian Phelps and I'm here
representing the Elm core team all of
these are going to have sort of
fundamentally different experience than
writing JavaScript it feels like writing
a different programming language because
it is a different programming language
one thing that's different about these
that's from from my experience is that
using a Jas alternative is actually
cheat code for hiring good people I
actually don't know how we hired anyone
at no ridic before we started using Elm
because pretty much everybody who
applies these days which is a lot of
people like we hired a head of talent
and she commented I have never seen an
inbound pipeline this strong in my
entire career all the cover letters say
Elliman them because the number of
people who want to use Elm is a lot
bigger than the proportion of companies
that have taken the plunge and are
willing to actually use it and then hire
for it something there's a misperception
commonly like intuitively you might
think Oh it'll be hard to hire people
how will we possibly hire people I admit
I don't know how we hired anyone before
Elm because it was way way harder so if
you're wondering like you know why might
I use something like this I can
certainly speak to my experience with
Elm I mean I talked about like okay
renders fast in the top jay s frameworks
emits smaller bundles on top J's
frameworks also know runtime exceptions
like it almost never crashes in practice
this is like our error logs this is a
JavaScript errors we've had like 60,000
plus since we started using Elm in 2015
Elm once it's not zero it's just zero
pixels like if I were to zoom all the
way and you could see like it has
happened it's not never not literally
never but I mean this is obviously not
something we're thinking about generally
speaking if it compiles it just works
and then doesn't
it's pretty great also this is a
completely separate package ecosystem so
all this stuff I just said about NPM
doesn't apply to Ellen projects like we
have our own package ecosystem it
doesn't have posted some hooks or
creates all hooks it's it's really fast
and it's really nice another thing is
the error messages this is like a really
common thing that people praise about
Elms so this is from the most recent
release of Elm which was last Monday if
you get a syntax error now it reports it
like this hey I was parsing it import
it's all I got stuck here this is maybe
if you tried to use JavaScript syntax
for imports rather than elm syntax
because it's a different programming
language it says hey I was expecting to
see a module name next like in these
examples it shows like multiple code
examples of like how to do it properly
and then it's like okay and you know
they all start with capital letters and
by the way go ahead and read this link
if you want to learn more about it like
this is a pretty I just picked this one
kind of at random but there are so many
examples of this we're like day-to-day
writing elm code like I just get this
level of help from the compiler just
feels really nice like I got I don't
know I don't know how to describe it
the best way that I found to describe
the experiences maybe by contrasting it
with my experiences whenever I find
myself back in the JSE ecosystem like
come on I'm maintaining one of my node C
allies or something like just imagine if
in your life building web you eyes like
things normally worked like I I don't
know how else to say it but like I mean
normally when I'm writing JavaScript
code like I'm installing a package I'm
like this didn't work with it why didn't
this work with this thing like in elm I
just installed packages Nate and they
normally just work okay whatever and
then I'm like I'm going to upgrade a
package so Mike lightweight this used to
work but now it it stopped working like
what's what's going on I'm like googling
stuff and now I'm like okay okay fine
and then I go back to Elm and I'm like
oh everything works again nice okay cool
everything is like this like it compiles
and it normally just works like III I
haven't been able to express this
feeling in any other way just then like
whenever I go back I'm just like am i
dumb like what how come I can't get
anything to work anymore but in Elm it's
just normal not a hundred percent of
time but normally things work out pretty
well and if that sounds interesting you
should check out the Elm website and
learn more but I also know from
experience giving elm talks and stuff
that a pretty small percentage of people
in the audience will actually go and do
that probably an even smaller percentage
will actually run the NPM
figman but I'm being realistic here if
I'm making predictions about the future
I know that you know this is a not
JavaScript thing and javascript rules
the web and I think that will continue
like at the end of the day I really do
think that the next big thing in the web
is typescript it's not going to be Elm I
don't think Elm is going to take over
the world I think typescript well this
graph will continue but that doesn't
mean that I necessarily am going to be
getting on this train
like to me I'm like yeah I think Elm is
much nicer I have no interest in that
and there a lot of people who feel the
same way just not as many as feel that
you know tights good as well if they're
gonna go with and that's fine I mean
really at the end of the day again the
point of this is not to win popularity
contests like pearl had won the
popularity contest the point is to find
a technology that you're happy with and
that you continue to be happy with over
the next 5-10 years etc I've been using
Elm for about five years and I
definitely see myself using it for the
next five years it's something that I'm
happy with and that I think is going to
continue to age well so my final
prediction is that I think that Jos
alternatives stay niche but that they
age well I think a lot of people who are
betting on these technologies today are
going to continue to be happy with those
bets so certainly with Elm so by the end
of 2020 I think they'll still be growing
we actually add for ellen conferences
this year fairly a lot of people I
talked to didn't know that but yeah I'm
still growing but not as fast as
typescript typescript is taking over the
world which Elm is not and that's fine
by the end of 2025 I think that they
will have aged well although of course
typescript will have continued to grow
and will at that point still be more
popular all right so to summarize it
started out by talking about the passive
I'll just choose boring technology and
everything will be fine not necessarily
a lot of times it's more about correctly
predicting which technology's end up
being something that you're happy with
over the long haul talked about
predicting is safer than following
blindly which can lead you into the same
kind of situation we would have been in
with Perl made a few predictions about
typescript webassembly
the web ecosystem and compiled ejs I
predict the tape script is going to take
over the jas world web assembly is going
to expand the web app pie rather than
replacing things I think NPM is going to
continue to have problems but ultimately
it's going to survive them and finally I
think that the j/s alternatives like Elm
closure script reason ml I think they're
gonna stay nice in terms of popularity
but that they're gonna age well and
they're a good thing to bet on so what
will I do personally well I mean I think
I've made pretty clear
keep using young because I think it will
continue to age well thanks very much
[Applause]
richer Feldman you have so much energy
thank you so much this was a great talk
to have as the last one I we have some
questions do you expect AI and machine
learning to make leaps in popularity and
development
what about pure robotics and automation
that's a great question so as far as
popularity goes I think that AI and mill
and I'll like already are trending that
way I think there's probably more to
come but I also think that if I were to
compare it to typescript I think
typescript is underhyped
relative to how far I think it's gonna
go I think AI and m/l are overhyped
relative to how far I think they're
gonna go I think the number of
applications the number of ways that
they're gonna be transformative at least
in the next decade is is not like we're
on could be like singularity we're here
everyone's thinking their way through
every problem and the machines just like
you know connect with our brains I don't
think we're gonna get there in the next
like decade maybe eventually but I don't
think anytime soon more more than that I
think if you look at the demos of today
of like what AI and ml are doing I think
it's gonna be variations on that like
incremental improvements on that not
really like earth-shattering stuff like
a lot of people are predicting in
European why Elm is not as popular as
react what is it missing to become more
popular yeah number one reason that Elm
is not as popular as react is that Ella
is not JavaScript I mean that's
literally it like if you're building
anything that is not JavaScript its
popularity is going to be infinitesimal
compared to JavaScript like the the
cultural momentum behind JavaScript is
just absolutely massive any programming
language that is not a JavaScript
dialect where the learning curve
compared to JavaScript is like anything
significant is gonna be really big and I
think that's that's basically going to
mean that I'm willing to go on record
and say I don't think that anything that
is not a JavaScript dialect in the next
10 years is going to get anywhere near
the popularity of anything that is
fundamentally JavaScript I think that's
just how strong the momentum is so again
but I think that's fine like you also
need to be significantly different from
JavaScript if you have any hope of being
significantly better than JavaScript and
like I think the Delta between my
experience and my Elm experience is as
big as it is because it's different and
that also is why it's not ever going to
be as popular
all right our app scale to millions of
customers and performance is critical
and doesn't support coats pudding though
yeah and is it is a deal-breaker for our
team solution look you boy that word
yeah sure yeah so that's a great point
um please get in touch with me because
basically the the steps that we wanted
to take we're like cool first let's make
the bundle size is really small with
code slimming and then we'll look at
what are people's remaining problems
like in practice like hey I have this
elm app and it's too big because of X
and what we've heard from people were
actually building L maps as they're like
actually they're not too big anymore we
don't really want to go to all the
trouble of code splitting so never mind
but if that's you and you're like hey
even if like it were just like 29
kilobytes that's too big for me or like
you know I'm gonna have a million lines
of code and it's gonna be you know
however much X that size please come
talk to me because we're trying to build
features based on like people's actual
needs and use cases rather than just
like Oh
code splitting we should like check that
off because everyone's doing it like we
want to actually solve the problem of
page load times and bundle sizes rather
than just like checking features off a
list yeah come talk to me all right
last question on this stage for you do
you think ECMAScript will continue to be
the dumb nsj standard yeah so that's
that's a really interesting question I'm
guessing where this is coming from is
like so there's ACMA script which is
like hey this is how java ships would be
and then there's typescript which is
kind of like becoming the default
compiler if I'm right if my prediction
is right and it ends up taking up taking
over what happens if typescript says hey
you know what like ACMA script disagrees
with us and we don't care we're gonna
keep doing things the typescript way
this is certainly not what happened to
CoffeeScript like CoffeeScript you know
dekma script ended up adopting some of
CoffeeScript stuff and then replaced it
so yeah I think it's a totally valid
question I think that III don't have
super high confidence in like whether or
not it will continue to be the dominant
jaya standard i think if it's not it
will be specifically because ACMA script
and typescript clash and typescript said
hey look we're not gonna change but i
think it's probably more likely than not
that if ACMA script did clash with
typescript in some way where ty script
was like yeah you know we're just we
disagree about what's right here I think
typescript would eventually cave I think
that's more likely I think it's pretty
plausible that one thing I've heard
people talk about is maybe I can't
script will come up with a standard that
says hey this is what ty
javascript is and it'll probably be very
close to typescript but maybe there'll
be some differences I wouldn't be
surprised if typescript said okay fine
we'll just like get on board and now
typescript becomes the the dominant
compiler of the Xmas script type system
so I think it's more likely than not but
I want to be honest that I don't have a
super high level of confidence in that
one way or the other
all right thank you so much everybody
switcher Feldman
[Applause]
[Music]